[Music]  that loves all of us equally mix it for  me I think I was his favorite pretty  sure tag was his least favorite girl we  can tell about this rally sometimes dad  would take me aside and say I don't play  favorites but I love you the most  I'm thinking you're know that the table  thing Craig doesn't know he was adopted  dad swore me to secrecy we bought them  from abanda hippies for a bag of  tortilla chips and a fresca the Josh  mention used to eat his own fingernails  as a kid how you doing knuckle snorts  you watch that show Game of Thrones  because been Ken reminds me that little  girl with a boys haircut  the Romney brothers stick together  because the campaign says we have to  [Music]